thank you so much I am so honored to be
here I am also a little nervous because
this is the toughest crowd I'll probably
ever face
I've been interrogated by Dennis Neill
on CNBC Power Lunch
I testified before a congressional
committee but the home audience in Omaha
Nebraska where I'd Buffett's hometown
and place of birth is definitely
something else so what I'd like to do
today is just take a few minutes to
introduce how I came to write this book
a little bit about the process of
writing it and how Warren and I work
together and then how it affected me in
my life and then I'll take questions for
a while afterwards I was a Wall Street
analyst I came to Wall Street in 1993
and in 1998 after five years on the
street I had the chance to meet Warren
Buffett when his company Berkshire
Hathaway bought general rate which was a
stock that I was following and at the
time all the other insurance analysts
decided that they would not follow
Berkshire Hathaway it was complicated it
was big the stock didn't trade it didn't
do investment banking business but I
like challenges and Berkshire was a big
complicated interesting company and so I
decided that I would follow the stock
and I was the only analyst who made that
decision at the time Warren Buffett read
my research he said he liked the way I
think he likes the way I write and he
called me and asked me to be the only
analyst on Wall Street that he would
talk to about Berkshire Hathaway and as
a result over a five-year period I got
to know him and his business I would
come out to Omaha about once a year and
we would have a meeting for an afternoon
I have raced through the Nebraska
Furniture Mart with him trying to keep
up with his pace which some of you may
know he's a very fast Walker I got to go
to borscht arms and then we talked on
the phone periodically and from the very
first report
that I wrote on Berkshire Hathaway he
called me on the phone after he read it
and he said you have an unusual mind
this is very insightful maybe you should
be doing something else because I had
written what people needed to know in
Berkshire in his mind and so he was
already thinking of ways to sort of move
me on to some other role five years
later I had become more focused on
things like terrorism after 9/11 and I
was following a lot of stocks but I was
still following Berkshire and in 2003 a
writer approached me about collaborating
on another book a book about Warren
Buffett but it was a topic that I really
didn't think was the ideal book it was a
fairly narrow subject and people had
begun writing these books about Warren
Buffett and the manager were invited the
investor of this type that type and I
see him as a very unusual person but
he's all one person
everything about him fits together in an
integrated whole and the book that I
wanted to read was the story of this
very unusual man you know the man who
thinks that rich people should pay taxes
the man who came from a right-wing
Republican family and became a very
liberal pilot politically oriented man
the the simple billionaire who has a lot
of jet-set friends the the person who
won't eat broccoli and yet you know has
dinner with Katharine Graham and her
grand banquet I wanted to know where did
this come from you know he fascinated me
and I thought you know this that story
is the one that would be interesting so
I called him and I proposed that he
write this book as a memoir and he
didn't want to do it he he never wants
to write a book he there are other ways
he'd rather spend his time like playing
bridge and especially above all running
berkshire hathaway so he turned the
question around on me and said who do
you think should do it I'm not going to
do it and I actually ended up
volunteering to take this project on at
the time I was a 10-year veteran on Wall
Street and I knew that it would mean
that I'd have to leave my job full-time
and I
was very naive about what it meant to
write a book of this sort I thought I
could do it in a couple of years but he
offered me full cooperation and that
meant that I could spend essentially
unlimited time interviewing him it meant
his friends and family would talk to me
it meant that I would have access to his
files and his correspondence and that
process alone would take a couple of
years as I got into it and discovered
what I was in for and the first day we
were in Omaha he sat down with me and he
said listen this book is your baby I
want you to have fun with it I am NOT
going to tell you how to write it it's
up to you who to interview it's up to
you what direction you take it in when
the book is done I am NOT going to ask
for any changes I also am NOT your
co-author I don't want it to be promoted
that way in any sense I only have one
request and that is that if my version
of the story differs from anybody else's
and you when you do your interviewing
use the less flattering version and that
was actually a fairly characteristic
thing for him to say because he tends to
be quite self-deprecating and so I
started working and he pointed me toward
the file room and he has two huge file
rooms and when I saw that I grasped the
enormity of my task because there are
hundreds of files there are files of the
companies that he owns the companies he
might like to own someday investments
he's considered in the past there are
files on different topics he's
interested in like nuclear disarmament
and there's files on people one of the
first things I found was a file labeled
Alice Schroeder that had all of my
correspondence with him which was that
was a surprise so I started to work I
spent I asked me in about 2000 hours
with him most of that time I was just
observing him i sat on the red leather
sofa in his office and I just watched
him work he would be on the phone he
would be reading you know I would listen
to him as he would make decisions as he
supervised his staff I also went to a
few meetings with him furniture store
openings meetings with managers and I
spent about I have
300 hours of recorded interviews with
him I also talked to him informally and
so I have a lot of material gathered
from him on all kinds of different
topics some of which I incorporate
directly into the snowball so that you
can hear him speak directly to you the
reader because I was having this
experience of having a wet amounted to
an extended conversation with Warren
Buffett and I wanted the reader to feel
that they had that too at the time he
was doing these lunches for the glide
Memorial Church where he would auction
them off on ebay for charity and the
luncheons were going up from half a
million to $600,000 for a couple of
hours of his time and I thought you know
this book is gonna sell for $35 and
people are gonna get the equivalent of
that in this book with all of these
questions answered directly by Warren
Buffett and I thought you know really I
should give them that experience of him
speaking directly to the reader not me
translating without the feel of weren't
talking to you so that's what I ended up
doing I ended up talking to 250 of his
friends and family and associates in
addition to him
the biggest challenge there was their
age I started using the actuarial tables
with the people who were over age 90 and
I worked my way down by age there were
people I would have liked to talk to
that I was not able to because they were
no longer available but I did get a very
large sample of people who've known
Warren throughout the course of his life
ranging from people he went to
elementary school with his aunt Katie
Buffett people who you know his his kids
his sisters you know just a lot of
people and in the end the book that you
have today is the result he did live up
to his promise and when he saw the book
right before it went to the printer and
read it he did not ask for any changes
and if you've read any of the snowball
you'll know that that took a lot of
courage because it's not his version and
I did at times choose the less
flattering version and I think it was a
remarkable thing that for five years he
really didn't know what I was doing or
working on and he refrained from
meddling and then at the end he just
step back and he's letting you read what
you're reading which is a relatively
unvarnished look at him and what he's
really like a far more complicated
person than that simple public image
that everyone has and he didn't try to
do anything to change that from
happening and I think that is something
that a lot of people couldn't I do I
would never have never so I give him
incredible credit for having done that
along the way I got to spend so much
time with him that he rubbed off on me
and I hope that readers of this book
will be able to get some of the useful
lessons life lessons that I had from
spending time with him he is the most
incredible manager of his time that I've
ever seen
and you'll see throughout the book how
he does that he's an amazing negotiator
and I'm included and described some of
his methods of negotiation in this book
one of them I call buffeting and I
became a much better negotiator for
having had the experience of working on
this book with him because writing a
nonfiction book with a living subject of
a biography is in effect an extended
negotiation and I also learned a lot of
personal things because I saw how he
treats his friends and you know there's
been a lot said about his family his
focus his incredible focus on his work
and how that affected his family and
that is all in the book but one of the
things that isn't talked about as much
is that he is so respectful of people
that he knows and he never criticizes
them and he has this attitude of almost
unbelievable tolerance for human nature
and I have seen he has friends that are
extremely eccentric he has friends that
disagree violently with him on politics
and philanthropy and all kinds of things
and how he gets along with them with no
friction just with a
because he doesn't get into
confrontations and he doesn't criticize
people ever not to their face not behind
their back and he's so graceful in the
way he does that it really had an effect
on me because I stopped trying to you
know control people through making them
be what I wanted them to be that's one
of the biggest lessons that I learned
and I also watched the way he sort of
sorts people into piles according to how
he judges what kind of people he wants
to let into his life he's very very good
at screening people for honesty and
selfishness and you know deciding to let
them into a circle or not and you know
my own radar got a lot better and I
think a lot of this is incorporated into
the book so I hope that as you read it
you can pick up on some of these meta
messages that are in there and it's not
just a biography and I hope that you
enjoy it there's a poem by David White
that incorporates a little bit of this I
think right now at a time of a lot of
worry and unrest I hope that a book like
this can be of help to people David
White wrote that this is not the age of
information this is not the age of
information forget the television and
the radio in the blurred screen this is
the time of the loaves & Fishes people
are hungry and a single word can be food
for a thousand thank you
so um with that I'll be happy to take
any questions that you have yes well I
think you can see risk management the
book is very much from beginning to end
about how we're in learned to manage
risk and it goes from a very micro level
when he was a child and managing pennies
and dollars all the way up to where it's
the very end of the book and he talks
directly about what was happening to
Bear Stearns last spring and he says you
don't ever want to be dependent on the
kindness of strangers in the financial
world if somebody asked me to come up
with a billion dollars tomorrow and then
he says well a billion I could but any
significant amount of money I don't ever
want to be in that position and so all
the way through the book is filled with
stories about long-term capital
management and about what happened at
Salomon and how to think about
possibilities for catastrophe in your
life and it's just pervasive that would
be the risk yes released on September 29
and so your question
you know people who've already read it I
actually heard from people who read it
in one day
read it overnight they stayed up all
night long they read the book I've heard
of more than one person who's read it in
48 hours it's I know it's not a short
book but you know people just gobbled it
down some people just yes
yes I'm 40% through and I've had it
since the 29th this is slow reading for
me it's not a contest
that's okay thank you thank you very
much I really appreciate that thank you
yes your opinion there's a chance we'll
see him in Washington working question
would he take the job of Treasury
secretary that's been suggested by Obama
and McCain no there's not a snowball's
chance you know first of all he loves
running berkshire hathaway dad is what
he wants to spend this time doing and he
won't be taken away from that but also
letting someone schedule his day full of
meetings the way that you have to do to
have a job in Washington he is just too
independent he would never tolerate that
you he just wouldn't do it he likes to
give advice behind the scenes and the
leverage and his time is really by
spending an hour on the phone with
somebody you know and then letting them
go execute it yes enjoying it immensely
as just a beginning but what is the
underlining there are you know two or
three words here and there that are
underlined the italicized words no it's
a regular underlining underlining
am I caught in there are sections that
are italicized where Warren is being
quoted he's being quoted and then if
something's underlined it's because it's
a proper name like the title of the book
or the title of something usually I fell
back and luck yeah I find an example
afterwards so I can talk about it yes
the italicized phrases are direct quotes
from Warren that are where he's actually
speaking directly to the reader so it's
a shift in the point of view where it's
he's talking to you they're taken from
my interviews they're from recorded
interviews and you know he's actually
just just talking yes
yeah Warren has read the book and if he
has what was his reaction he has Reza
and I you know I don't want to speak for
him I would like for him to give a
reaction if he has any but you know
we've talked since and you know we're on
good terms so yeah he's been constructed
but I'd like him to describe his
reaction I don't want to preempt him
yes his friendship with Bill Gates um
you know the book has a lot of
information in it about that it
describes his first meeting with Bill
Gates there's a really charming
photograph that was taken at the party
where he first met Bill Gates that shows
had them at with a seaplane that someone
was kind enough to give me I described
Bill Gates is like a third son the
dynamic when you're around the two of
them together is really charming if
there is a warmth between them that is
just shows this fondness and almost
tenderness and you know Bill Gates does
not have you know people think of him as
this sort of all inspiring business
figure and also kind of tough and
there's this real warmth between the two
of them and they also talk about
business at a speed that is so rapid
that it's difficult to follow the
conversation when you're when you're
around them you know there's no
competition between them whatsoever they
just delight in each other's company yes
well you know I hope that we just resume
a normal relationship going forward I
can't you know that's really going to be
for him to decide you know that's all I
can say on that projects for me in the
future I don't really know what I'd love
to do is go on my honeymoon because I
got married in April and it's been it's
been kind of a busy time my husband
David Moyer is back there in the
audience he's teas go he's on the tour
with me he's an executive search
consultant so he's doing business from
the road while we're touring but you
know other than that I like as you can
probably guess I like interesting
challenging difficult projects from
following Berkshire Hathaway to Warren
Buffett which was really the ultimate
analysis of anything any project I could
ever take it on of something analyzing
and figuring out Warren Buffett was the
most amazing experience and most
interesting I don't know what I'll do
next but whatever it is it'll be
interesting and challenging yes Warren
and Omaha he's never really happy when
he's away from here he really isn't the
first thing he's always thinking about
when he's not here is when can I get
back to Omaha and I always saw that
whenever I was traveling with him
forming the person you know he is deeply
rooted in the Midwest I spent a lot of
time studying the history of Nebraska
and you know his father as a Republican
congressman really had that Midwestern
Republican strain that was very
influential in Congress right around the
time when Warren was very young it was
an isolationist strain it was very much
you know small government pro-business
very much anti-war know
or Wars and a lot of warren's views were
shaped initially by that early in his
life and then he broke away from that
but what he kept was the modesty the
thrift the courteousness the respect the
simplicity that you associate with this
and politically one of the things that's
very interesting from his mother's side
of the family they were Democrats
her father Warren's grandfather was a
tremendous idealist who had taken Byrnes
mother to see William Jennings Bryan
speak when she was a little girl and you
know that the sentiments embodied in by
William Jennings Bryan really have still
trickled down to some degree through the
Democratic Party today and we're very
much part of the air in Nebraska
you know when Warren was growing up so
Nebraska politics was nationally
important at a time when Warren was
young and I do think that his love of
politics his love of communication came
somewhat out of that atmosphere yes when
mr. Buffett was married he said that he
spent six percent of his net worth on
the light Suzy Buffett's engagement ring
when Bill Gates took Melinda here for a
surprise diamond shopping at four shines
mr. Buffett advised him to spend 6%
[Music]
[Music]
you want to stop it for signs it was yes
we live out of state you can save the
sales tax
you know they ship they do ship um yes
we love for signs this came from Porsche
and this ring came for Porsche lines oh
we love or find I think I've been cut
off yes yes you mentioned Katherine
Graham your introduction and in her
autobiography she talks about Warren
Buffett quite a bit at how much she
learned from him and yeah it also seems
she was pretty charmed by him too and
how would you characterize Warren's
version of their relationship well I had
more fun he talked and talked and talked
to me about Katherine Graham and I have
put more of that in the book it was just
the most entertaining part of the book
for me to write because you know he
found her fascinating entertaining you
know her high society was both
attractive to him and at the same time
he saw it as this observer and saw it as
kind of bizarre and she was always
trying to bring him up and you know get
him to dress better and and she taught
him a lot she he learned you know how to
eat a lobster all these things and at
the same time he was her business
teacher and she leaned on people for
advice to a remarkable degree and so
they were almost like the leading each
other through things that were very
unfamiliar territory and they were
equals they were peers because both of
them had vast gaps in their knowledge
that they helped each other fill in and
they were truly I mean they were deep
deep deep friends but him telling me
about his introduction to Washington
society and some of the events and
places that he went with Katherine
Graham and his reaction to that were are
some of the funniest things that I ever
heard from him and I put it all in the
book
where yes
another biography Never Say Never
I've been approached to do another
biography and I decided not to do that I
don't want to take on a project like
this again at least right now you end up
spending 12 or more hours a day carrying
somebody else's life around in your head
and you know more about their life than
you do your own and you're living their
life and affect it and it goes on for
years I know more about the history of
Nebraska than the history of Texas where
I was born
far more so it I have room in my head
for Warren Buffett's life and I know
that I'm going to continue to be talking
about him for the rest of my life I'm
not really sure that I could add another
person in there you know I only have a
room got so much room in my head for
people other people so yes no I did not
you know the terms the auctions that he
does for Glide that the deal is that
they're their exclusive for the person
who buys it and to have an affected
journalist there taking notes would be
now I heard about the master words
people those luncheons people do ask him
investing questions but a lot of them
have been about personal people ask him
about personal advice and that's
something that more and more people ask
him about
yes
the future of berkshire hathaway i do
talk about that yes i talked about
berkshire the business and i do talk
about succession and i'm not giving it
away now it's in the book we go from San
Francisco and then to Seattle and then
we just kind of do a sweep around the
country from there any more questions
one more the most surprising thing I
knew him as a business person when I was
an analyst you know and he was someone
who could snap off an answer to any
question just like that when I worked on
the book I saw him during a time period
that may have been the most difficult of
his personal life or certainly one of
the two most difficult periods not long
after we started work on the book his
wife Susan was diagnosed with oral
cancer and then suffered a long battle
with oral cancer she recovered and then
died of a stroke only a few months later
Warren has been portrayed by some people
as a very kind of cold almost
emotionless person and he does have a
side that can be very brusque and very
you know businesslike to the point that
it can be very surprising to people but
what I saw during this time when Susie
was ill was this just trasimede
suffering and pain and grief that was
overwhelming and it that story is told
in the book it's a sight of him that you
know I think that people who even know
him well have not seen because he hadn't
been through an experience like this
before that was a surprise how
vulnerable he is how dependent he is on
other people for emotional support
okay thank you